so most people I'm sure in this in the
sophisticated London audience will have
seen doctor Strangelove and there was a
kind of legend that Kissinger was partly
the inspiration for Peter Sellers
character in that movie the the German
accented uh theorist of nuclear uh War
but but that's not right
um it's actually a kind of amalgam of
Herman Khan and ferna Von Brown not
Kissinger because if you look at Doctor
Strangelove he's a he's clearly a former
Nazi uh and a rocket scientist
Kissinger is a refugee and an expert by
the early 1950s in well your special
subject the defeat of Napoleon which is
what he writes his doctoral dissertation
about
finds himself suddenly drawn into the
world of nuclear strategy but I
happenstance really I think it was
because Harvard wouldn't give him a
tenured professorship he didn't want to
go to Chicago and he got offered a job
at the Council on Foreign Relations to
act as rapporture for a committee that
was thinking about U.S nuclear strategy
and he pretty quickly took over that
role and turned and turned it into his
book I mean he turned the the minutes as
it were of the meetings into the raw
material for a book that made him famous
now what this book argues uh does as you
rightly say at first blush sound crazy
uh it argues that there should be an
option to wage a limited nuclear war
because
at this point in U.S history it's the
Eisenhower era you only have two options
if the Russians take aggressive action
give in blow the world up that's the
choice and Eisenhower had set this
rather deliberately up as a binary uh
set of Alternatives because he felt that
anything else would let the military run
Riot as they somewhat had under Truman
Kissinger's point was this is nuts we'll
never ever stand up to the Russians if
our only sanction is Armageddon we'll
just end up giving in to them because
nothing will be worth the threat of
massive retaliation so in that sense the
book starts to to become a little less
crazy it argues that there ought to be
an option if the Russians for example
use massive conventional forces in
Europe to use what became known as
Battlefield nuclear weapons to check
their Advance otherwise you lose all of
Europe because you just don't have the
conventional forces to resist the Red
Army
two interesting points one Kissinger
later changed his mind about this not
long after actually said come to think
of it maybe that would be pretty hard to
pull off a limited nuclear war that
wouldn't escalate but secondly and
crucially even although he rode back the
theory became Central to NATO's strategy
for the rest of the Cold War I mean
there were Battlefield nuclear weapons
they became a crucial part of both
superpowers arsenals and you don't build
weapons like that if you don't have a
theory of limited nuclear war so
although it never happened uh it could
have happened and it was certainly a
strategic option for the rest of the
Cold War
how did he get on with the Kennedy
administration
had a very interesting relationship with
the Kennedy family
he became involved in politics as an
advisor to a Kennedy opponent a
republican Playboy billionaire who
wasn't terribly intellectually profound
uh
nobody like that could ever run for the
Republican nomination today of course oh
wait
Nelson Rockefeller was no no Donald
Trump though and and I don't mean to
imply that he was he was nevertheless
somebody who preferred to buy an author
than to read a book and so rather than
trouble himself with reading nuclear
weapons in foreign policy he hired
Kissinger to be a foreign policy advisor
in Kissinger and he clicks I think
Kissinger loved the idea of this
aristocratic figure with his massive art
collection and multiple lovely houses
and also Nelson Rockefeller had marked
Kissinger's intellect and saw that he in
fact was a pretty shrewd strategic
thinker but Rockefeller kept losing I
mean he just lost every time three out
of three bids for the Republican
nomination end in failure and each time
he loses Kissinger is kind of gunned for
hire as a strategic thinker well John F
Kennedy liked hiring Harvard professors
in fact the administration in 6061 is
largely staffed with people that he's
rounded up in Harvard Yard and kissing
is approached by Kennedy before he's
even won the election and invited to
lunch and Kennedy lays on the charm
Kissinger ends up in the Kennedy
administration admittedly as a pretty
small player trying to Fathom this new
and unfamiliar world of White House
politics and why is it an unfamiliar
World apart from anything else you've
got the president bonking everything
that moves
upstairs uh while people are trying to
manage the most dangerous moments of the
Cold War downstairs I mean this is kind
of unfamiliar for a guy from small town
Germany uh who's who's you know he's
seen some stuff in the war but this is
this is a whole different I nearly
called it a bowl game
which brings us on to
um to Vietnam
um and your discovery of the 1965 diary
and uh tell tell us a bit about
um the way in which Kissinger's mind
evolves with regard to the uh increasing
American involvement in Vietnam well
you'll know Andrew the feeling of
excitement when you get a golden
document something that is absolutely
quotable and quotable and and really can
make a book when I found the 1965 Diary
of a trip to Vietnam I remember feeling
enormous excitement and it got only more
exciting as I read
unlike many professors who comment on
foreign policy matters
Kissinger wanted to get out of his
Harvard study and go and see what the
hell was going on this is coming already
by 65 the biggest issue facing the
United States and Kissinger who remember
had been in the military uh didn't shirk
from going to the front line he went to
Saigon as an advisor to the U.S
ambassador in South Vietnam but pretty
quickly got out of the city and started
to see for himself what was happening
and to me the impressive thing is how
quickly already in 1965 he realizes the
whole thing is a complete disaster and
it's a disaster for two reasons one
there's this horrific ungainly American
bureaucracy running a mock with five
different agencies all engaged in what
would have been a few decades later
PowerPoint presentations about how well
they're doing and at the same time uh
there are is a an incredibly corrupt
government in Saigon which is clearly
incapable of existing on its own he
comes back and essentially tells his
colleagues at Harvard we have to find a
diplomatic way out of this and he begins
working intensively on that problem it
really takes over he ends up in secret
negotiations trying to start
conversations with the North Vietnamese
in Paris in 1967 works extremely hard to
try and get a breakthrough thinks he's
getting close and learns a really
valuable lesson about diplomacy because
he's really made a fool of by the North
Vietnamese representative in Paris the
The crucial point to understand about
Vietnam in the late 1960s and this is
often forgotten is that the North
Vietnamese had no intention of reaching
a diplomatic settlement with the United
States they thought they were going to
win and so they play footsie with
Johnson and later on with Nixon while
all the time planning military Victory
this is very true in 67 they're going
through this whole charade of well maybe
we'll take the call maybe we'll have the
meeting while at the same time planning
the test offensive which they launched
the next year so this is a pretty
interesting lesson for Kissinger in the
dark art of diplomacy and you do also
point out that there was another reason
why he wanted to go to Paris in 1967 and
16. well I'm really I'm glad you brought
that up because it's a reminder I
learned something about being a
historian doing this it's a reminder
that you can't find everything in the
documents there are things that you can
only know if they're about safe to you
I thought I had written a pretty good
chapter on this 1967 episode
and indeed I thought it was one of the
best in the book
and then I went and had dinner at the
Kissinger's having I thought finished
the book this was before I got all the
extra documents
and as I Was preparing to sit down
Nancy Kissinger said that she was
clearly not going to stay for dinner but
she wanted to say something
Neil
why do you think Henry was really
spending so much time in Paris
in 1967.
this is a terrible moment of this story
because you realize that you've
completely missed something and I had
completely missed something because it
wasn't there in the written record at
all he was there because she was there
she had been working on her doctoral
dissertation on interwar France at the
sorbonne so it turned out that one
reason Christian didn't really mind
being led down the Garden Path by the
North Vietnamese because he was quite
happy to spend the whole summer in Paris
seeing Nancy Kissinger as she became
Nancy McGinnis as she was then with whom
he'd been having a relationship since
1964. since the Republican National
Convention in San Francisco
where they had met that relationship
remained secret was not reported on in
the Press until the early 1970s and I
think the main reason for keeping it so
private was that he'd only got divorced
shortly before 1964 he had two very
young children and he just didn't want
it out there so this was a salutary
reminder that when confined as much as
possible from serious and scrupulous
archival research
but there are things you can only find
out if people actually tell you and this
is something you didn't have with
Napoleon
um well that brings us on to 1968 and
the whole question of Richard Dixon uh
what Nixon saw in him why Nixon turned
him what he thought of Nixon at the
beginning is fascinating your your
description of of the relationship
between these two men which obviously is
going to be a key aspect of volume two
the kernel of it is very much there in
volume one so we'd like to talk about
about that well I was sure I was going
to be able to find the origin of their
relationship and and reveal that it
began much earlier than anyone had
realized and I was especially sure when
I discovered that the professor Elias I
mentioned earlier had been a Nixon
advisor and in fact it got close to
Richard Nixon in the 1950s when when
Nixon was a pretty unknown congressman
so I thought ah there has to be a moment
when these two men met and I'm going to
show that the relationship and therefore
had Deep Roots no
in fact despite the Elliot connection
they didn't meet until the end of 1967
and this was partly because
Kissinger avoided Nixon
what I hadn't fully appreciated until I
did the book was that Kissinger in
common with most people at Harvard or
for that matter in New York loathed
Nixon or as after Schlesinger put it
and so when Nixon reached out to
Kissinger in 1960 after Rockefeller had
lost the nomination Kissinger invented a
trip to Japan to avoid taking the
meeting now we all try to avoid people
we don't want to meet but to go to Japan
to avoid someone suggests you really
really really do not want to meet them
and and that meant that there was this
curious Norm relationship at the heart
of volume one a non-relationship that
only finally became a relationship at a
cocktail party in New York in late 1967
a very awkward meeting between the two
Kissinger had been rude about Nixon
publicly he'd said he was unfit to be
president and there they were one of
those somewhat awkward occasions and lo
and behold it's the socially inept Nixon
who breaks the ice
uh how does he do it I already told you
this by telling the professor that he'd
read one of his books
and indeed he had because I was able to
show my research that Nixon had read
nuclear weapons and foreign policy he
probably read much else that Kissinger
wrote and so the odd thing about the
relationship is that it turned out not
to be personal it turned out to be
purely intellectual and Nixon read
Kissinger and admired him and despite
all the rebuffs uh he finally ends up
offering this man a job there are all
kinds of theories about why that came
about incidentally some of them of
enormously complex and conspiratorial
detail I think fundamentally it was an
intellectual Affinity that Nixon was the
first to spot and in the second volume
would you like to give us a little
preliminary view about I mean obviously
the second volume is likely to be much
more controversial than the first you've
got Chilean Cambodia and all the other
great issues uh what um how far are you
through the research writing and and how
are your thoughts coalescing well I'm
probably about 60 maybe 65 of the way
through getting the stuff
more like 10 through processing it and
I've written an introduction which I'll
almost certainly discard but which is
there just to help me organize my
thoughts and and that's about as much as
I can say because I I really haven't
made up my mind I have no idea what the
subtitle will be I guess it won't be
controversial if I call it Dr Evil uh
I I think that the challenge and it's
hard to communicate to people who
haven't been through this process of of
immersing yourself and in thousands tens
of thousands of pages of material is
that you you make up your mind about
something at quite a late stage in the
process once you've gathered all the
material and once you've read it all
through and I'm in my case I read it all
in chronological order and then I sort
of build chapters rather laboriously
lead it all in chronological yeah sorry
how on Earth do you do that well it's a
slightly um it's slightly nerdy can I be
nerdy for a second please um I I set out
to try and do this in a different way
from the way I'd done previous books by
taking advantage of Technology
so although there's tens of thousands of
pages of staff uh it's in a it's in a
database I can see the facsimile of
every document my wonderful research
assistant Jason was going around all
these archives when I was teaching and
just taking pictures of page after page
after page and we've also digitized them
so that there's a searchable text uh
also there in the database and my rather
old-fashioned way of working is when I
finally conclude there is no more stuff
or we're into diminishing returns and
any more stuff is going to be of
marginal use I just sit down and I plod
through it and I try and relive the life
day by day and sometimes hour by hour on
the basis of what I've got and I have to
say I do find it that one time at one in
the same time incredibly tedious
and Incredibly exciting because there
are moments of tedium there are dull
letters there are letters that know
where they're all full articles that you
wish you didn't have to plow through but
as you read through and relive the life
with the archives all coming together
with all the different pieces of the
jigsaw suddenly arranged in line that is
the moment when you see what actually
happened ranker's great phase phrase
so volume two is miles from that point
of of real understanding and that's why
if you want to ask me questions about
post December 1968 that all I can offer
you will be lame hypotheses that's
really all I've got at this point